de la lumière pour protéger les plantes
des champignons c'est le pari de la
start up
ubi boosting créé en 2010 est par deux
chercheurs d'avignon est aujourd'hui
installée à saint nom la bretèche
elle a inventé une machine composée de
panneaux lumineux qui se fixe sur un
tracteur le principe est assez simple on
vient exposer les plantes en
l'occurrence par exemple des lignes à
une un flash du vc donc une dose
lumineuse très courte mais très intense
ce qui va enclencher chez la plante un
processus d'activation de ses défenses
naturelles ce qui va la rendre plus
résistantes à différents agresseurs
notamment dans le cas de la vigne le
mildiou et l'oïdium
en 2020 la société a commercialisé une
quinzaine de machines en champagne un
bourgogne ou encore dans le bordelais un
investissement pour les clients entre 36
milles et 54 mille euros qui permettrait
de réduire de moitié l'utilisation des
pesticides uv boosting a développé cette
technologie pour permettre justement aux
agriculteurs aux viticulteurs de réduire
leur dépendance aux produits fongicides
conventionnelle c'est parti d'un constat
assez relativement partagés que
aujourd'hui les consommateurs et les
producteurs ont pour la plupart envie
d'une agriculture plus durable et plus
saine pour l'environnement
depuis sa création la start up a
embauché une quinzaine de salariés et
prévoit de recruter des commerciaux mais
aussi des ingénieurs comme loïc employé
depuis 2010 est mon travail c'est de
faire en sorte que cette solution soit
la plus efficace possible à la fois
en collision production mais également
pour travailler avec tous leurs
partenaires de recherche qui nous
aideront ensuite eux aussi de leur côté
à optimiser et à rendre plus efficace
plus efficiente moins coûteuse
enfin juste améliorer la solution après
une première vente en afrique du sud
ubi boosting souhaiterait à l'avenir se
développer à l'international tout en
continuant bien sûr à commercialiser ses
machines en france pour protéger les
futurs millésime